[Music]
nick you've been living at the sunset
tower for over a year they love having
me there you owe them six hundred
thousand dollars okay i'm gonna deal
with all that but i'm gonna get this
next roll
and when i do
all of that changes then i'm back not
that you went anywhere
nicholas cage oh my god i love you
he was so good in the rock what about
gone in 60 seconds have you seen croods
too no i'm 44 years old why the [ __ ]
would i see croods too i've seen
face-off and con air we got another
offer what's it about you head to
southern spain and you attend a wealthy
gentleman's birthday party
i would never do that it's a million
bucks nick
[Music]
i'll take it
the guy that owns this house what's his
name
look if javi wants me to [ __ ] his wife
or watch me watch him [ __ ] his wife
that's a no-go do you understand there's
no bueno claim
[Music]
in the cage
i am so happy that you are here
is this supposed to be me it's
protest
i'll give you 20 000
[Music]
what have you got there divine
inspiration
i'm paranoid let's just get up on the
count of three and run
they're coming grab my hand
you're heavier than you look i have a
very big head
you go i'll never forget
mr cage
it turns out we could have just walked
around wow
[Music]
you